Well, let me ask you this,
because right now
we're showing some live pictures
of what's taking place in Brazil
right now.
As you
know, and we've been reporting
all afternoon here on CNN pro
Bolsonaro supporters as supporters
of the former president Jair Bolsonaro
have stormed into
various government buildings
in that country's capital.
It looks like a replay of January six,
this time in Brazil.
As you know, Congressman,
you just have to look at the scenes
on our on our screens right now.
We've been playing
some of these screens earlier
or some of these images.
Earlier today,
one of these pro
Bolsonaro supporters
was sitting at a desk inside the capitol
in Brasilia in Brazil,
and it looked like a scene
right out of January six.
What are your thoughts
as this is taking place today?
Well,
Bolsonaro was an authoritarian leader,
and I stand
with the democratically
elected leadership in Brazil.
And he basically used the Trump playbook
to inspire domestic terrorists
to try to take over the government.
And you're right,
it looks a lot like January six
in the United States.
And right now,
Bolsonaro is in Florida,
and he's actually very close to
Donald Trump.
He should be extradited to Brazil.
In fact,
it was reported
that he was under investigation
for corruption
and fled Brazil to the United States.
He's a dangerous man.
They should send him back to his home
country, Brazil.
And so if I'm gathering
what you're saying, Congressman,
are you calling on the
Biden administration
or authorities in Florida to return
Bolsonaro, put them on a plane
and send them to Brazil
as soon as possible? Absolutely.
Bolsonaro should not be in Florida.
This the United States
should not be a refuge
for this authoritarian
who has inspired
domestic terrorism in Brazil.
He should be sent back to Brazil.